I'm from I don't know it's just a joke
to lighten the mood in the newsletter
alright you've been here before for
those who didn't listen to the first one
because they're dumb start from real
quick kind of two minute recap what you
did pre point pre becoming the victims
everywhere I don't know
voice of bitcoiners everywhere as little
sup freaks sup freaks yeah so I
I found Bitcoin in college I was
studying economics at DePaul University
in Chicago and while I was in college
studying economics I worked for a
managed futures fund and we were a fund
of fund so we indexed CTA traders
predominantly into in a suite of funds
and my job there was an analyst and some
of the markets that the CTA's that were
we're indexing traded we're currency
markets and that may meant I had to
follow fed tea Leafs and central bank in
the world and so early on in college
sort of found Bitcoin and was studying
it and at the same time working at this
fund having to write commentaries on why
our fund was performing against market
movements and so I had to know why
currencies removing the way they were
which meant reading a lot of Fed policy
and over the course of three years
working at this fund I sort of realize
that the Fed had no idea what it was
doing I was getting more down the
Bitcoin rabbit hole and sort of found
Bitcoin in that way I decided to leave
the fun about a year and a half after
college to go learn about UX UI design I
was very infatuated with tech and the
whole space so I went to go learn how
apps were made so I decided to learn via
design first
so I took it as digital design bootcamp
designation I think they were recently
bought by lambda school in Chicago and
that was a summer 2014 and I moved up
here to New York in like late summer
2014 and I got a job at a software
company learned about the backend of app
development and stuff like that so learn
the whole code stack behind the design
and then after about 2 years there I
decided to quit because I thought I was
gonna be able to get a job as a product
manager but apparently if you're haven't
built anything getting a job as product
manager is pretty hard so I had a little
stint of unemployment there but the
whole time was still learning about
Bitcoin studying Bitcoin and then about
a year and unemployment year and a half
and unemployment I decided to start the
newsletter the bent it was June 2017
markets were going crazy as you quantico
crypto markets were going crazy as we're
running into the the run-up of the bull
market then so I had a bunch of friends
family reaching out emailing texting me
I you're psycho like what do you know
about this yeah you're the Bitcoin guy
like what's going on like should we buy
all this
she would buy Ripple she biota I was
like oh god no my one claim to fame from
2017 I've never taken my victory lap but
I'm gonna take it right now is on the
way you ever seen the CNBC video of
Brian Kelly on TV - no - dollar 50 cent
XRP be like here's the order book here's
how easy it is going to Pawnee X here's
how you buy it so I was sitting at my
buddy's apartment in Raleigh North
Carolina and we were drinking before we
were ready to go out and I think he had
it on bike Tebow was like you know scene
B's here whatever and it played and I
lost it I was like wait what just
happened and I was like rewind play that
back no way I just saw what I think I
just saw played it a second time we're
like crying and laughter
we wanted a third time and I videoed it
on my phone I just couldn't help myself
I was like this is absurd I tweeted it I
woke up the next day and I was like man
I really like fry take that victory lap
no but like every once in a while now
people will retweet it and they're just
like do $2.50 was a while ago yeah
what's it at now like 30 cents if I
don't even know well we're not gonna
make this XRP hate session we're we're
all friends on the Internet today kind
of all right so we're the first 33
thousand blocks
what what what happened with the what
did you abortion what what was that
experience like um that was a crazy
experience was a relatively short-lived
experience but isn't crazy very grateful
that I had the opportunity to work there
especially at the time that I did yeah
so I started the newsletter in June of
2017 and then noticed a person who's
somebody's a person non grata a parcel
now my buddy Louis was tweeting at
stoolies that they should be buying
aetherium and i DM to him like and this
was aetherium was like approaching
$1,200 and I was like kindly like I
should meet up he shouldn't be pumping
this stuff to the stoolies especially
like at this point in the bull market so
we met up for some drinks just to talk
about the space and he's infinitely
fascinated by it and he convinced me to
start the podcast and so that summer we
started brainstorming podcast and
started recording at barstools offices
and this was before I started working
there I'm still unemployed looking for a
job and it was lucky to be able to do
the content stuff while I was unemployed
and sort of just I was always hanging
around the bar stool offices at that
point and Louis needed an Account
Manager on his podcast ad sales team so
I took that job and basically yeah I was
able to get a front row seat to the
rocket ship growing when there's hitting
a takeoff speed
and at the same time bit coin and crypto
markets were going crazy so I was the
Bitcoin er in the room telling everybody
the stop don't buy one chain don't buy
iota I was on the run down a couple
times it was a crazy fall winter that I
spent there was only a parcel for like
eight months but it's incredible
experience and I really admire what they
do what the important way in particular
is done to slowly but surely build a
brand over time and as you know we were
talking about it earlier there on the
Nasdaq yesterday flex and so my favorite
part of yesterday was probably Dave in
the suit and tie and big cat in like his
bomber jacket I just like having on the
mall but the the crazy thing about
barstow I think is just they've done
what a lot of people previously have
tried to do they never veered from we're
just gonna tell you what we think right
like a lot of people tried that and then
when they get the backlash they kind of
cave to it they backtrack they apologize
whatever and like these guys just they
were like look no yeah this is what we
believe they lean into it
which works and has worked for them for
some time then on top of that again we
like to talk about time preference a lot
in the Bitcoin world and Dave is
somebody I think exemplifies a low time
preference handing out papers starting
in 2014
slowly building the blog over time and
now he just company's worth half a
billion dollars just from showing up
every day I went back a couple of days
ago and I looked for I remember he
tweeted at one point that like a picture
of the first newspaper and I had
forgotten that the top half is you know
barstool spores and it says for the
common man by the common man so the
motto stayed the same for 15 years but
the bottom half of the front page is a
Hooters ad
I was like man this guy was really
gunning for the a Sunday and I think
they got Hooters back as a sponsor this
year to 2019 so that and then once I
went down the like Dave rabbit hole like
historical tweets
I was like what other ridiculous things
and I remember he made the Bitcoin video
yes I tell them 17 there's a video of
him and he's like I don't know what this
[ __ ] is bitcoin bit corn whatever like
I'm just all in though some guy told me
this how I get rich funny story I
literally set him up with a wallet right
before he recorded that so I walked out
of the room he shut the door and hit
record on that video and I like went
downstairs I was like you should not be
yeah he was like holding his treasure up
at the cameras like oh my god so the old
the first time I discovered that some of
the guys at bar store into Bitcoin was
Nate I think like Nate either like
tweeted about it or a lot or maybe
really damaged I forget but at some
point like he revealed himself as being
interested and all of a sudden I was
like oh [ __ ] like these dudes have a lot
of influence and if they position
there's like gambling this is gonna get
bad real fast cuz like they got an army
of people who are gonna do what they say
to do it was just kind of like oh [ __ ] I
mean that's why I was happy I mean not
saying that any even fluence on any of
these any of the barstool employees but
I was happy to potentially be a voice of
reason some breaks in there I'm like
alright guys stuffs blowing up and
crashed many times in the past yeah it's
slow and Steady's the game here probably
most likely my opinion bitcoin is the
only one worth buying it definitely is
the only one worth buying in my opinion
but yet no I mean they lean into
everything like we were talking about a
zillion beers they know when to touch
when something's hot and when to lean in
and that's something that Dave's really
honed in on is leaning in on stuff my
favorite thing that I've learned from
barstool you don't even remember saying
this to me but it's actually something
you told me when you came to record the
first podcast episode I think I asked
you something like as you're leaving I
was like would you learn and you're just
like show up every day
yeah and like it's always stuck in my
head from uh that's literally what that
man did it is for 1415 years showed up
every day and if you I think Erica
Nardini the CEO gave an interview and
she was like yeah I got to the office
and like there's like uncashed checks
lying everywhere these guys had no clue
what they were doing if you go back and
look at like the old rundowns
it's Dave standing in the cocoa office
which really looks like he's like
parents attic basically rest in peace of
the milonov and he's standing there and
he's somehow videoing himself and then
you got big cat and KFC like sitting at
their home basically and they're just
talking [ __ ] to each other but it's
entertaining it's funny and that's how
you build the audiences like people who
want to watch that stuff come back every
day day after day for years and then you
go what they got today
ya know I mean I was I mean it's still
still a since high school so I was a how
do you 28 okay yeah so I was in college
first time I like I felt like a
sophomore 31 yeah he had a they had
Philly I'm from Philly in Philly the
Philly bar salal fit had a really good
writer it's not there anymore
tall Maurice Moe and I really liked his
takes on Philly sports and the culture
around that is a Philly baby if I've
ever heard one
think he's working at actually uh he's
in New York somewhere now but yeah I
started reading in high school and then
when I was actually at the Paul in
Chicago and college big cat actually
lived not too far from me so I I would
see him walking Stella like every once
in a while and it's funny I've seen the
brand grow and now I'm just happy that
they are where they are now because I
think they're a great example of show up
work art and it took a lot of hard work
oh for sure which a lot of people take
for granted these days and like we were
saying a lot of media companies try to
skirt that hardware could clickbait and
other stuff like that
he also talking about like leaning in he
understands like the trends more than I
think people give them credit for my
favorite is the recent hiring of vin dog
the meme Lord VIN 63 year old man who
he literally just takes good hey we got
a meme or brewing over here are you
ready and like as much as it's comical
and entertaining whatever like that is
the where the world is today right you
overwhelm an opponent you know an
intellectual opponent on the internet
with memes like you win internet points
they understand that yeah no they
definitely understand that and it not
highlight something we talk a lot about
Bitcoin to like the under the sovereign
individual thesis like it is you talked
about in that book like it's going to be
independent content traders that win the
minds of the masses especially as
traditional media sort of gets too
bloated in monolithic to to move like a
barstool does like nobody could be as
brash as barstool is because they have
too much quote-unquote reputation that
they're worried about tarnishing and
Dave just takes it the complete opposite
way and it's worked out for them I mean
yeah in the modern age of digital media
barstool is obviously winning what's
your favorite segment that they do
across the whole company I'm a big fan
of the wonton Don oh I do I think he
actually does a very good job of
introducing a bar stool audience to to
other cultures and he does a it's not
your average travel show but it
definitely is a unique way to get
introduced to to other cultures outside
of America yeah I do not think you're
gonna pick that one I I think that my
favorite thing that's happened with a
segment is now Dave's become a celebrity
when he does the reviews like the fact
that he walks out of a pizza store and
awesome there's like 20 30 people taking
pictures of him like what like what
world do we live in yeah I mean I'll be
sitting at my desk at home and I'll just
hear my wife laughing in the background
while you're watching the pizzeria she's
like yeah she loves it
no that's some that's another thing you
leaning into yeah it just when they
moved to New York they did a few pizzas
of use up in Boston I think like every
once in a while and then New York being
the city of Pizza just lean into that
and come out
I've got a [ __ ] app for it i
standalone app um they probably will
actually Dave probably wants this to be
forgotten segment but uh I'm gonna
remind everyone remember the Dave walks
to work yeah he would walk down the
street he was live-streaming and all of
a sudden people started to like
recognise where he was and I remember
the one day that some guys home stool he
saw him walking down in videoed and got
his bald spot and it was like mass chaos
for like three days I was like Dave what
walks to work went away yeah that was an
incredible one I mean that's the beauty
that's another that is a beauty of of
days it's like interactive with the fans
yeah that's something I try to do with
our pocket like sub freaks what are you
guys doing like it's walk us through
kind of everything cuz you start with
the newsletter I'm sorry if you got the
podcast yeah that's about it was so via
the newsletter which is a daily
newsletter six days a week now and no
you had it Saturday yes a standard
trying to make SATs the standard so we
started the SATs standard guys so seems
like a weekly ranting genius
that's Matt O'Dell he named that but
yeah I mean I then it all started
organically it's grown organically which
I'm very happy of I don't think we've
forced too many things up to this point
and again so the newsletter started his
family and friends reaching out and
again before I even like reached out the
barstool or worked there I had the
mentality about what do that bring a
barstool like voice to bitcoins is so
hard to approach for a lot of people so
I just try to make it more approachable
for it with my family and friends of
mine and then it's taken on a life of
its own obviously a lot of people are
reading it now and then the podcast was
the next iteration of that and it's
people are like alright I like your
writing let's do a podcast what's the
process for coming up with what to write
every morning I write every morning and
I I'm assuming we have the same process
but I want to hear yours first I just
wake up and see what I tweeted the day
before and pointed something like
alright spend an hour writing on this so
some days I have better
idea than others but yeah at some point
you got to write and just kind of pick
something around with it I think we're
very somewhere in the like I got to
write something so let me quickly search
for inspiration whether it's something I
tweeted something somebody else tweeted
or like an article and then just what do
I think about this I don't know yeah and
I see you know you hit publish and like
you're done yeah I mean obviously I try
to give attempt to bring a good
perspective on everything everyday and
be as factual and educational as
possible like I was I was happy with
today's bent because it was more
technically focused in something you do
do that more than most I think is that
you whenever there's updates oh I
remember one like that was the inflation
bug and like you're able to not only
explain the technical aspects of it but
also then pulling all these different
like I probably have discovered more
people in the Bitcoin like hardcore
technical community through you than
anybody else yeah no I don't know where
you find them but you're always like oh
my friend I'm like a random person
it's pants just being on Twitter for so
long I've been curating a bit quaint
less since like 2015 I think that's like
is it public or private it's public it's
got like five five hundred followers now
which is pretty cool for a list but yeah
I feel like I've put my ten thousand
hours and and and know who to follow and
where the good information comes in like
again go back to a sovereign individual
you had to create and filter your own
news sources and find the signal
yourself it's not gonna be brought to
you you got to really work hard for and
over the last six seven years I've
really been sort of filtering my
information feeds and being here in New
York were blessed to be able to go to
meetups like bit devs where you have
some of the core developers showing up
and explaining what they're working on
so that certainly helps and yeah I just
feel like again I've put in a lot of
time trying to understand how this all
works and feel like I'm in a unique spot
to sort of
translate that for some people and
another in a way which is more
digestible than technical documents or
something like that at the end of every
newsletter you put your like what we got
a random thought final thought I know
thought where do they come from because
some of them are hysterical you know the
one I think I saw just before you hit us
one time with like I like sitting in the
shower I was hungover and there's not no
worse feeling than being hungover
sitting in the shower
ya know it's literally a final thought I
think I had taken a shower before I read
the vent that morning was like see just
whatever you whatever thought you had
just randomly yeah like this morning it
was like a big big shave day for me as
like I went and [ __ ] like trim my beard
up and that was it then because at some
point you got to get it out and I don't
I'm gonna final thought it's been a lot
of music lately like a song I'm
listening to I'm writing I'll just link
to that YouTube say I like this I like
this song alright and then the podcast
you do one to two interviews a week plus
you've got the rabbit-hole recap mhm
what let's talk about the interviews
first and then Matt Odell was like the
MVP surprise out of nowhere one day just
like Oh Matt Odell now it's gonna do is
every single week I was like these guys
are [ __ ] incredible
so where what was the point of starting
the podcast initially people want it
more than the newsletter and they wanted
to hear from the people I was writing
about directly and again being in New
York that everybody comes through New
York yeah at some point or another and
there's a lot of acquaintance New York
so it was just easy having been gone too
bit des and meeting these developers and
people working in the space it was
pretty easy don't you develop a light a
level of trust just to be like hey you
want to come on and discuss this stuff
on air and so yeah that was the impetus
for that and it's been incredible hunt
forged some great friendships learned a
lot doing that alone and then Matt and I
started a rabbit hole recap in September
tour yeah September of 2018
did you know that you wanted to start
like another type of show or did you
guys just do one and then you're like oh
let's do it again
no we
tap Matt on the shoulder intentionally
being like we need a weekly show god I
really love your [ __ ] Matt had been on
the podcast earlier that year he's here
in New York and yeah I never I don't
ever just want to put content out to put
content out like I want to make sure
it's has value and so like I got to a
point where I thought like I was forcing
interviews and something like a weekly
news show is something with Matt was
something dependable where you keep
putting content out and it's not forced
it's it's actually got a legit strategy
and and sort of like the word I'm
looking for
cadence and structure if you all makes
sense how do you think about like
freedom of speech in today's world now
that we've seen the great purge of Zero
Hedge
I think freedom of speech is uh I know
you have a lot so for those that don't
know I've seen I think you go on to
tirades on Twitter over the last like
maybe twelve months or so that I can
remember and one of them was all around
the Zero Hedge situation so just like it
happened Suraj got banned there's a
whole bunch of controversy around who
led to that banning who participated why
they got banned was a daxing was it not
all stuff it's been a couple of weeks
now like what's your thoughts now yeah I
mean I don't think we're fired up or
less fired up I mean that's a that's the
thing like as time passes it feels like
you're powerless and nothing you do like
I'm kind of feels like it's over yeah
exactly I don't lean I was fired up is I
was I think it was exactly three weeks
ago at this point as it was this time
three weeks ago but I still think it's
[ __ ] up that's a girl had just banned
like they don't think they should have
been and zero ed for me personally like
after 28 2008-2009 crisis like they were
actually a very good source of quality
information and yes they've strayed away
from that a bit with a lot of
shittier pieces on their site but there
still is very good content on their site
you just slept again you don't have to
know how to filter it and I think
they're banning is an example of free
speech being attacked in the modern age
again going back to the onus is on the
individual to filter information my
opinion these days and to have Silicon
Valley tech companies sort of dictating
who they believe should be able to speak
and not speak on their platforms I just
it just doesn't sit well with me so like
I don't disagree with anything you just
said
I always then jump to like what is the
answer or like if I was Mark Zuckerberg
Jack Dorsey etc I always struggle with I
don't know if there is an answer her
'but man
pick one sign guy over here orbit and
make it something like urban maybe may I
mean owning your own data and like I
think that may be the answer but I say
it been saying more recently is people
just need to speak up like a lot of it
shouldn't take people with tens of
thousands of followers on Twitter to
speak up on behalf of other people like
individuals the silent I believe there
is a silent majority out there who does
feel the same way that freedom of speech
is being attacked and feel like they're
powerless I feel like more people need
to speak up and demand that free speech
be protected and then you can roll that
into privacy as well our privacy is
being eroded as at the same time as free
speeches and big and enhan especially
with financial privacy like money is
dictated as free speech here in the
United States and all right that makes
me think we're I think you're the one
today he said he said delete point base
about the stuff I've a said [ __ ] clear
view but now you said Dylan Columbus
when you think of privacy how do you
balance like there's information photos
etc that's been put into the critical
public sphere that
some of it was done intentionally right
you were I posted footage of ourselves
five years ago on the Internet and
they're still out there somewhere some
of it's unintentional I have a photo
with you from five years ago and I post
it you don't even know that I posted it
right so we can come find it etc that
type of information being used for fish
recognition and things like that like
how do you think through the framework
it's inevitable all right I mean but I
would agree with that it's inevitable
but like we should have again
constitutional protections in place
where it can't be used against you as
aggressively as it is like I think we
have to pass when go down right now
either get back towards the Ark of
freedom freedom of speech privacy
freedom to move money or we export the
Chinese surveillance social credit
system to the rest of the world and
that's what I say in the newsletter law
we are erecting the digital panoptic on
and being cattle herded into it well
right now it's just credit score's and
Instagram feeding you ads based off of
what you talked about with your wife but
in a second they can flip the switch and
just be used against you and one second
you're getting fed ads the next year not
being allowed to buy plane tickets
because you said something uncouth yeah
or you went outside
yeah to another country and there's a
virus okay
now you can't fly back to the United
States Yeah right
but literally I went to my cousin's
wedding in Mexico and I think United
Airlines literally emailed me four times
before the flight being like if you went
to China in the last 14 days don't show
it to the airport and I was like well
thank God I didn't but if I had how do
you get home yeah and how do you yeah
right and that and that's for like a
quote-unquote health related incident
you're basically saying well what if it
was just because you posted a stupid
picture right or you are friends with
somebody
slippery slope and that's why I
mentioned Herbet or you want to build
systems and Bitcoin falls into this
category two systems where it's just not
possible to do stuff like that like
Bitcoin being a distributed peer-to-peer
caches somewhere and if you are running
your own full node and you have control
of your UT X's and you are broadcasting
the transactions yourself it's very hard
for people to stop you from doing that
do we get to a world where everyone does
that I hope so I think that's an ideal
we should strive for I can't say that
with any degree of certainty and you
think that's a world we should go
towards definitely we should strive for
it
yeah because again if not we're getting
we're getting a social credit score
system exported here and we're gonna be
subjected to that as well you know it's
like Minority Report the part to me that
is really interesting as you think
through kind of how all this is
happening is you have two competing
forces you've got probably people who
like you and I who are more in the camp
of we should protect freedoms and like
not go down that rabbit hole and then
you've got people who make an argument
that the world would be better if we go
into that right so like when it comes to
the privacy stuff it's like oh we could
stop crime if we have everyone's you
know GPS on their phone and we know
where they are like well yeah okay maybe
but like we just took everyone else's
freedom right and it's kind of like do
you look to protect people or do you
look to actually protect the freedoms of
people I mean I think we should do the
latter and I think the former is being
proven to be completely wrong like you
are harming more people than helping
where people okay why caml regulation
like explain that
every time you have to give up your
personal information like a lot of the
Bitcoin exchanges including the one in
sponsored my podcast you which one is it
give a shot up use the code stacking
SATs when you download the cash up
you're gonna get ten dollars and ten
dollars gonna go to Al's the cross do
you see the hard work it takes to
clearly articulate the advertising off
the dough we didn't even have to read it
shut off the cash yet but when you do
kyc a.m. Eliot's give up you're a lot of
times your driver's license passport
home address where you work how you're
receiving funds and you give it to these
companies and they hold it in databases
that have proven to be completely
insecure like we have the Equifax X
target hacks hacks any hack you can
think of well those are the ones we know
about well the Department of Defense
just got hacked like last year they came
out announced that last week like the
people who are forcing these regulations
on a scan you could can't even protect
their own systems so I think a facial
recognition wasn't there somebody that
like Customs and Border Patrol or like a
contractor or something they got hacked
I had a bunch of images of everyone's
like faces yeah yeah that and I believe
they had like the x-rays that could like
see through crazy sees your clothes like
I got hacked as well at some point and
think so I'm not certain on that but the
point remains a lot of these companies
and government agencies that are forced
in kyc on people are getting hacked and
then you have people's date of birth
social security number home address
which freaks me the [ __ ] out pictures of
their driver's license passport on the
dark web is being sold to the
for it's not even bidding war they just
get sold at a certain price and your
informations out there and you're
vulnerable and then what they are
proclaiming to protect us from anti
money money laundering laws the banks
that are supposed to
basically enforce these laws become the
biggest perpetrators of the money
laundering like HSBC had bank teller
windows purposely fitted for it Mexican
drug lords suitcases briefcases oh I
didn't know that yeah that's wild
yeah and and well as they grow as well
the Wells Fargo was a is my big knock on
Warren Buffett it's like hey man you
know what he say long suit or short
suitcases like dude Wells Fargo's one of
your biggest you know holding should one
of holes in your portfolio and they they
pleaded guilty didn't even find it had
pled guilty to help in this inoa cartel
launder millions of dollars like
billions of dollars with HSBC was
billions of dollars and they got slapped
with a couple hundred million dollar
fine such as the cost of doing business
at that point so you're not really
protecting anybody getting them a bank
teller window to be refitted for
suitcases is that the whole time yes
that and that's like and then they tell
you that you you need to do this stuff
for your protection and and then behind
your back threat and just like
completely ignoring the laws and then
not getting in trouble for it when they
get caught there and you just have to
get slapped with a fine it's a cost of
doing business where you [ __ ] get
caught selling a dime bag on the corner
in Harlem you're going to the [ __ ]
Rikers for years it's [ __ ] up yeah I
one of the things that I think will
definitely change over the next five
years or so is it's not only gonna see
the decriminalization of all like the
possession of small drugs and you know
like I said it's gonna actually become
with the social pressures on anyone who
feels differently
can't believe that you think we should
put humans in a cage because of it oh
yeah that's a good point to bring up
like the whole basis for the anti-money
laundering specifically is the drug war
is like the number one justification and
the jug war is an abject failure it's
been going on for decades and people
have not stopped doing drugs people not
stopped selling drugs they've actually
made more money doing it now they make
more money doing it now and then you
push people towards you so weeds a
Schedule one narcotic like you can't use
that for medicinal purposes it's
becoming more commonplace now but for
the longest time you couldn't and
regulated opiates were pushed on the
masses you have an opiate crisis and you
watch the Netflix documentary
pharmacists incredible right like when
they showed the video so for this I
don't know Netflix got a new documentary
I'll call the pharmacist and it's a
gentleman his son dies buying drugs gets
murdered and he goes based on like a one
man it was kind of like a taken vert you
know except for as like an old white guy
yeah but it was it's a critic I'm gonna
[ __ ] figure this out yeah he did hard
hard detective work which which need
powers-that-be don't want to do anymore
and they just want to throw all these
regulations on people and just throw
people in cages in a lazy fashion a
pharmacist I forget his name but he did
hard detective work and eventually found
his child's killer brought him to
justice and then like the rest of the
documentaries he was a pharmacist and it
opened his eyes
it opened his eyes and he he noticed a
bunch of people coming in buying opiates
from dr. claw it yeah from dr. Clegg it
and he's watched the opiate crisis
destroys community and the video that
shocked me was when he so when you'd say
hard detective work he's literally like
in his car to am like videoing through
the windshield with the lights off type
[ __ ] calling people going through the
phone book and calling everybody within
like a ten block radius of where his son
was murdered yeah
but he he shows a video where it's
ten o'clock midnight 2:00 a.m. whatever
it is late at night and the doctor's
office is open and that's when she's
actually giving out all of these
prescriptions and all of a sudden he
goes and then I couldn't believe it
there was a New Orleans police officer
at the door and he wasn't there to bust
them he was there to run scared yeah
it's like what it's a me and that's a
shining example the two-tiered system
we're subjected to and that's why again
that's why I think more people need to
speak up like this [ __ ] up I can
people just put up with it and that's
why I decide to dedicate my life to
writing and talking about Bitcoin
because I think it is an imperative
technology moving forward because it
allows us to sort of wrest control of
our sovereignty financial sovereignty
particularly away from these people who
do not care about you and do not follow
the laws that they want you to follow so
the event that recently happened that
really opened my eyes to just like no
one is safe is the Jeff Bezos dick-pic
situation right like the richest dude in
the world
got hacked and we how about them trying
to blame it on the Saudis too and it
wound up being his side P is just
sending it to her brother yeah but like
here but here's my whole point it's like
I don't know what's true that's true
right like maybe he got hacked and the
girlfriend's brother sold it for money
who knows yeah but just the fact that
the richest man in the world is even
possible dick-pic Jeff well that's a
whole other thing I mean come on you got
billions of dollars let that let that
flex for you stop sending dick pics if
you're doing it out there I'm happy to
say I've never sent one of my life I'm
with you it's probably because my wiener
is not worth sending
no but it's just this idea of like the
richest man in the world is not safe
from the same things you and I aren't
safe from right and like in some
triumphant way we're smarter cuz we
don't send dick pics he put like like
dude what everyone in the world that is
an adversary of you is gunning for some
sort of dirt some sort of angle on you
whatever and it could simply be of
somebody sent you a video you open it
and bam your phone is compromised yeah
it's the Information Age we all have
access to the same powerful technology
encrypt encryption based technology I
think it levels the playing field for
this stuff doesn't matter how rich you
are how powerful you are
the Internet has its ways to to find it
out there's a bunch of people out there
who are getting good at the Internet and
can bring you down pretty easily d so
that that's like a very targeted I want
to get Jeff Bezos but the thing that
scares the [ __ ] out of me so do you have
a Alexa or Google sound yeah so Ann are
same so we don't have any of this stuff
right but I saw a clip of it was kind of
like multiple versions where people have
infiltrated the ring internal cameras
and they it's an audio and video so they
can see into your home where you set up
the camera and they start speaking to
like a dude on his couch eatin popcorn
or a little kid or whatever they're like
hey man we watching ended like what the
[ __ ] right and they're like hey you hear
me over there and you're like dude you
literally put a camera up for somebody
to hack into in your home and gave them
a microphone to scare the [ __ ] outta ya
you run it on Wi-Fi they can do that and
then if you have like nests they can
literally [ __ ] with the the temperature
of your house I think the you know at
some point they'll be able to unlock
your doors cuz it'll only blue to
Amazon's trying to get that to people
with ring they're trying to make it so
you can like have when you're not home
and Mazon can open your door and leave
your package inside so they don't get
stolen but people do that's convenient
again and that's the weird predicament
we find ourselves in to the information
age a lot of people
seating freedoms and privacy for
convenience and that's I mean where we
are still monkeys at the end of the day
we're still animals and we have
animalistic tendencies and we have
reptile brains that and just over
millions millions of years of evolution
still react in certain ways and we'll
take convenience over privacy and safety
just because it's easier right so that's
one thing we do need to focus on in this
day and age is you really have to think
about what you're seeding when you when
you bring these technologies into your
home like I I have a little shield for
my camera on my laptops but like yeah
the my laptops can hear me I don't have
Alexa or a Google home and I'm sure
apples that were somebody who's hacked
I'm just assume that everything you own
has been hacked
yeah I'm sure somebody's able listen and
some microphone some capacity might I
mean look it's exhausting if you took a
really hardcore
privacy first mindset you would switch
out devices you would you know not bring
certain to fight like you wouldn't have
a cell phone right I mean like all this
stuff and just life would suck okay so
it's like there's definitely a balance
but like so I I draw the line at the
smart speakers for sure so no Alexa
Google Holmes maybe that anything else
that you won't bring into your home ring
cameras already yeah no ring like I live
in an apartment building my neighbor has
rang on his door I'm like what the [ __ ]
are you doing cameras because Amazon
he's the drop a package ah that's what
the front doors for like the doorman
what else that's that's off the top of
my head that's all I can think of yeah
yeah yeah I try to be as low tech as
possible and only the bare necessities
it's also a thing where it's not only
the decisions you make though in your
home you get to make the decisions but
when you walk outside like
I forget I think they're gonna study
maybe was in London a person who walked
to work the average walk to work how
many times a camera recorded them and it
was like hard 40 times yeah me something
stupid number where you're just like how
does I even possum can there's dating
app hinge is a dating app or is
literally tracks you as you walk to work
and tries to partner you with people who
have a similar commute that you do
really yeah I didn't know that yeah no I
mean I'm not on it that's apparently
that's what the kids are using one of
the game one of the things the kids were
you want to talk god no that's a curse
step I want to China I think China's
taking all that data and then it's
making people do weird things like what
like you think China's like secretly
programming dance moves in America no I
just I just don't think in incentivize
towards anything productive yeah that's
that's true yeah the part that I think
is crazy when it comes to all this stuff
is we live in a world where if you went
you asked like fifteen-year-old kids
would you rather be a professional
athlete or like a tick tock star it's
like a growing percent of them they'll
say they want to be tick tock star yeah
right and so they're like getting
habitually addicted to this like
feedback loop that's a screen and it
kind of reminds me of the like ready
player one type you know like there's
the the one world you go into the portal
of a different world like we're
basically there already yeah I mean I
experienced this [ __ ] on Twitter I'd be
lying to you if I didn't get dopamine
hits from likes and retweets and [ __ ]
like that and I try to limit it to that
and I and it's double edged shorteez I
use Twitter as a networking networking
platform the better LinkedIn better
delete a LinkedIn LinkedIn s-- worthless
in my mind if you want you can answer
some LinkedIn messages I get from the or
software developers I couldn't take any
more the cheesy LinkedIn posts that one
day just rage quit I was like this is
not worth my time you I don't think I've
ever to do this but you'll love this my
add is a LinkedIn Savage
so he used to have Facebook my mom was
like yeah knock that should I shouldn't
wait too much time on it then he had
Twitter for a little while and like
quickly went down the like I'm an old
white republic and you know just saying
all kinds of crazy [ __ ] so like my
brothers and I basically had the
interventional a hey man chill out and
so he's on LinkedIn cuz you know he did
pretty much no one's gonna make the
argument that he can't do business there
right so my friends the new scheme is
they will literally screenshot the his
post he comments us and he rips people
apart busts like those post you're
talking about where they like guys like
aha you know this year we grew our
revenue 10% and we hire 20 people and
like super self-congratulatory
the one I remember is I have like 16
friends all screenshots ended me he like
comment on some dude he's like you know
hey Sam I see you are really good at
learning how to self congratulate
yourself but I never seemed to see any
of your business to stick around for
more than 12 months but you should like
stop focusing on yourself and actually
focus on building a business like you
know the rest of us are tired of reading
your [ __ ] or whatever and I was just
like he's not wrong mr. Pompeo no the
LinkedIn troll I love yeah but you can't
post that in 2012 anymore if there's
like 20 18 I'm gonna come to the defense
of your dad we need more of him was
matching a LinkedIn we probably do that
was having this conversation earlier
today people are becoming more and more
afraid to speak their minds which is bad
again going back to free speech people
are self censoring which is not good I
don't think well here's my challenge to
him I said look two things one why the
[ __ ] friends with all my friend
something did and then I realized that
somebody discovered him commenting and
they told everyone else and everyone
started question him of course which
like you know shout to my friends
they're geniuses for that and then too I
was like dude what do you get out of
that and he was like not like I just
need to learn his lesson you got a voice
like right I and her son told somebody
over the weekend a group of group of
dudes we were in Brooklyn one wife and I
remember what's going on over there that
country in Brooklyn
God all right group of dudes too much
cloud chasing it's a it's a cloud
chasing nightmare over there so a group
of dudes cloud chasing like taking
pictures in front of mural and I'm like
what I'm like you could tell they were
just like about to post the Instagram
and I saw them from two blocks away I'm
like walking with my wife stroller a
stroller
oh yes and they they walk by I mean
they're like looking at their Pixy tell
it which one should we post those a
guide you get a good one and they're
like you could tell they're like ah [ __ ]
the stroller but it's like to be honest
though once you get to like young dad
status I mean no one can touch you yeah
like what are they gonna do turn around
like talk [ __ ] to you in front of your
wife and your kid no I was hoping so I
was hoping it would had the balls to but
that's the thing like everybody has this
online persona myself included I'm
guilty of it too especially on Twitter
but uh like the WWF yeah I mean Twitter
I think Twitter's marathon or the
meritocracy I believe they were trying
to post an Instagram or it's a more of
art show yeah more of like make your
life look better than it actually is
have you seen the Instagram account
these influencers in the wild I've seen
I've seen people have I've seen people
shared on Twitter or I've seen it yeah
and like there's a bunch of dudes taking
pictures of girlfriends on the bench I
was when I was at my cousin's wedding
we're sitting on the beach the day
before and I kid you play like he hits
me and it's like and I'm like what she
hates me two more times and she's like
points and there's a one girl standing
ten feet from the water another girl
standing with her feet like barely in
the water and they're taking a picture
of the groaning of the water she's
posing posing posing goes on for like
eight nine ten minutes and you're like
you gotta have a good like did you get a
good one right but I've never seen this
before they both come together they're
looking like hey what should we post
exact we use describe they go sit down
five minutes let your play like punches
me like what they're back
same girl take a picture of the same
girl do the whole you know straight
again go sit down 20 minutes later
they're back at third time I literally
almost got up it was like hey you all
got a chill like what are you doing with
your life well it just you spent the
last hour I
I already know trying to get one photo
and by the way I don't think that the
photo is gonna change anything about
what's going on you're already in Mexico
people know I promise is the dopamine
hit worth it but a great test is is your
wife on Twitter she's not she's not all
right
so plane is on Twitter and one day I was
driving I pleaded actually when I first
met her she had more followers than I
did a guide like got 50 under G like
4,000 right and she still gives me [ __ ]
about it today and so she still got like
a big fan I she's got like 20 something
thousand almost 3,000 followers so it's
not like her Twitter is ghost town right
she's got stuff whatever but I handed
her my phone one day and I'd said
something like controversial people are
all freaking out so again go back to
like I'm addicted the dopamine just like
everybody else I was like what are they
saying
and she refreshed the notifications and
notifications popped up refresh it again
puffed it again sex me because this is
fun and she was just like every time you
just refresh like there's something
there and it hit me I was like holy [ __ ]
we're just rats and hamsters on the
wheel man yeah I mean and it feels it
feels like we're but it feels like we're
coming more cognizant others to like but
does it it's unhealthy you change your
behavior and now that I have a child I
try to it's because it makes you it
really puts in front of you that there's
more important things in life but you
don't want to go yell at that Vince
roles want to go hey yo my kid yeah when
I go actually live life and I'm still I
still have my moments from on Twitter
way too much like my wife but definitely
say that I'm on Twitter way too much
still it is an addiction and it's
actually her studies coming out that's
affecting the young people terribly
it's creating terrible social heart
hierarchies particularly in middle
school particularly affecting the girls
to like you have self-harm and suicide
rates for 12 to 17 year old spiking
because of the sort of hierarchy that
social media is causing for them I was
with a guy who's an eighth grade teacher
but I think he teach or I think he's a
science teacher maybe but I couldn't
resist asking like what's going on in
middle school right just like you're in
it every day man you're doing
hand-to-hand combat with you know
thirteen year olds like what are they
doing and he told me that the biggest
things are one they all know everything
before the teachers break they're always
on their phones to is the things that
they are consuming aren't like complete
[ __ ] it's all tick-tock and like all
this kind of stuff and because the third
thing is we don't know that the bullying
is happening and there's all the
bullying that like you and I probably
saw when we were in school where it was
like physical you know bullying or like
people would point me fun not sit with
them at lunch like all that [ __ ] I'm
sure some of this slow goes on but he's
like the bad [ __ ] all happens online and
the teachers are completely removed from
it so what they actually have is like
these like rats they like develop
sources and like you know little Johnny
tells the teacher like hey man must be
really mean to Mary and the teachers can
I try to I'm like dude we want you to
teach all right like but this is what
you're spending your time on he's like
yeah we have to because the kids are
freaking out about it yeah and it's a
guys talk about this a lot on the
podcast too like we're just born at this
inflection point and we don't know how
this stuff is going to again being
animals and monkeys that have an
evolutionary process like this change is
so drastic and so quick I literally
don't know how it's affecting or
beginning to find out how it's affecting
our psyche and our social interactions
but it's playing with fire right because
the change is so drastic the information
spread is so instantaneous and we're
literally chemically trying to react to
this change in real time and it's
very hard if not impossible because the
pace of chains work living through right
now is far greater than any pace of
change we've ever lived through up to
this point in history
speaking of pace of change the macro
economy is on stilts it is wobbling and
it feels like it's just waiting for
someone to kick one of the legs out and
this whole thing's gonna topple over
because the Carano virus might be that
that kick yeah I mean theoretically it
would make sense that there's something
that causes economic slowdown in
activity and next thing you know like
you pop the pin yeah right or I guess
the pin pops the bubble right yeah and
what do you think's going on like I'm
literally staring at Twitter right now
and hashtag stock market crashed 2020 is
the third trending topic right now well
it's an after number four hashtag Trump
crash well it's the way we instruct our
economy like again going back to time
preference we live in a very bleep here
rashard coined the term a high velocity
trash economy we the incentives of our
economy are such that like we're forced
to go after gross at all costs and I
think that's basically the main crux of
the issue that we're experiencing right
now I heard about this earlier this week
in the bent there's a thought experiment
I thought experiment like a question
posed by an economist I forget his last
name Tomas something he says when you're
thinking about economic growth and
economies and how you want your economy
to run you got to ask yourself the
question do you want to be a man on the
bike or a man standing on his own two
feet and when you're a man on a bike you
have to keep going forward if you stop
momentum you're gonna tip over and fall
over and hurt yourself whereas if you're
a man walking then around two feet you
have the opportunity to stop recalibrate
look around without falling over and
hurting yourself and the gross at all
cost economy we live in right now when
you live in economy on the bike
it's a debt-fueled we went off the gold
standard in the 70s and since then we've
been printing a bunch of money and
moving production or trying to stoke
production in in the present by taking
money from the future and promising
growth in the future more importantly
and we're getting to the point
particularly with the way demographics
are set up in a lot of these countries
in America specifically that it just
doesn't make sense that we're going to
be able to keep growing at the same pace
so macro trends right now demographics
are one of the biggest it's the one
thing that I didn't understand three or
four years ago but now it's like whoa
stop you know stop the alarm the whole
nine yards is demographics lead right
and if you watch the demographics you
can pretty much understand what's gonna
play out
Japan's a great example you know how
this happened a number of years ago and
the u.s. is probably better because well
at least there used to be such a high
desire for immigration so you kind of
continue growth not just by your own
birth rates but also kind of importing
people from other countries but when you
start to look at that there's this weird
world of like you or I can't stop kind
of the Train right and like it's headed
where it's headed we can analyze that we
can talk about it we can warn people all
this stuff but like that trains going
what we do have control over though is
what we do right and I think this low
time preference when you start to like
not only do low time preference but also
the anti-consumerism your life like
drastically change like you've really
changed the decisions you make on a
daily basis what you buy you know all
this kind of stuff it's very free yeah
you're just like I don't need all this
[ __ ] that and then it's an important
step towards fixing the problems we need
to invert the way things work right now
everything across sectors across
across life is very top-down like the
government obviously in the federal
government here in the United States
makes a lot of decisions for everybody
in the United States I think that needs
to change drastically and it starts
individually by maybe turning away from
a consumers lifestyle trying to save
more get your own balance sheet in order
but I think we do really need to get
back towards localism because what you
have fed is a perfect example of this is
people who think they know better than
everybody else trying to micromanage
complex systems and that's impossible I
think one of the biggest causes of sort
of the the troubles we find ourselves in
today is people fundamentally
misunderstand complex systems aren't
even aware that they exists and we live
in them so the Fed trying to manipulate
the economy of 320 million people with
interest rates of expansion and
contraction of the monetary base in my
opinion is very top-down and you have 12
people trying to micromanage a complex
system and that's just not possible
these stuff has to be emergent and
emerges from the bottom up from you
making personal decisions to save more
instead of spend more and then you move
that up to the local level or your
Township here your town and you guys
make decisions for what you need at that
level you stand on your own two feet or
not on a bike you don't have to go
growth it all costs at the at the city
level you can decide as a small
community what you what is best for you
at that given point in time where right
now it's a complete opposite and it's
kind of like the false promise of like
oh well of course we're gonna listen to
the the government right like the how
could they not have our best interest in
heart how are they not smarter than us
and then once you understand now they're
just people and like by the way the
people who are running those
organizations usually have done nothing
else other than optimize their life to
get that to that role yeah and that's
the scary part to me yeah a lot of them
never run businesses a lot of them are
psychopaths sociopathic and just want
power
and yet they really don't understand
they're completely dislocated from the
people they're representing I mean
that's why Trump's president right like
he I actually think that his rise to the
presidency is going to go down as like
the most obvious thing in hindsight you
know ten years from now people look back
and be like of course that was gonna
happen
but we've almost forgot like you know
when he first got like two people are
like what the [ __ ] just happened it was
people a little man far away from the
coastally it's saying we need to change
I will do anything to get change
I'm not saying Trump being president is
good I don't I think he somehow
convinced people he was the common man
yeah that he was gonna fight for them
he's gonna fight for him yeah and
whether or not he's followed through on
those promises a lot of people will
debate I tend not to pay attention to
politics as much as possible because I
do think like we're gonna look back in
retrospect in this time like you never
know that that the empire is crumbling
in real time you only look back in
retrospect and are able to say oh it was
obvious that the Klein had set in and we
were in the middle of it I think we may
be in the midst of a huge decline that a
retrospect people look back and be like
holy [ __ ] like that and you're talking
about not like a in 2020 you're talking
about like over a decade or something or
maybe even wanted that yeah I mean not
this single point in time but yeah I
mean you can go back I mean 2008 might
be like the what historians point at me
like ow that was that was the first
crack in the armor that was yeah I mean
that was basically when you can point to
and be like all right legitimacy of the
system is gone
how much of that so like you and I are
close in age and I always describe to us
and ADA is like the time where people
around our age we're old enough to pay
attention and kind of like realize
something was happening but not old
enough to have enough assets to really
like be hurt by it right if you were 30
in 2008 you pretty much got like either
wiped out or kind of yeah you get
knocked off the feet a little bit if
you're older than that some people were
well protected somewhere and if you're
16 to 22 years old like you knew what
was going on especially if you were
studying economics you know which we
both did but you didn't get hurt by it
and so you almost like grew up seeing
what could happen but didn't have the
negative effect of it so you just don't
trust the system yeah no I mean I was
seventeen in the fall of 2008 again
taking a just tapping chance taking an
elective economics class in high school
and so we I was fall corner I was in
that class and my teacher is very astute
like gentlemen this is not good to the
tarp bill and even then like a 17-year
old going through the tarp bill like the
clauses that politicians snuck in just
to get a past as the country was in
quote/unquote dire straits like it just
smelled a [ __ ] reek the [ __ ] and
so I definitely went into college with a
note your enemy mentality with all this
stuff and yeah I'm a I'd be lying if I
said I wasn't scarred by that that
happening at that particular point in
time and yeah I don't trust it at all do
you have you seen the I think it's an
HBO documentary panic and it's where
they bring together all the major
players I haven't seen I've seen like
interviews with them I've seen like
clips of it I haven't watched a little
thing yet okay so there's the most
telling thing and anything I've ever
watched read anything about the global
financial crisis is in there
they've got who's the Goldman guy big
tall bald guy awesome Paulson yeah and
at one point they're going through this
short where he's about to go in front of
the government and ask for money and
he's like I knew that we needed you know
700 billion but I knew I couldn't ask
him for that
so what I do for Hill baby no he's like
so what I do
I answered their questions right and
they then like basically show him the
hearing and they're like so much Paulsen
like how much money are you gonna need
here he said well you know we don't know
exactly and he's like busy [ __ ] and
they cut back to him he's just like
cackling laughing and you're just like
don't tell me these people to know what
they were doing yeah like he is telling
you that he knew what he needed to do
went in front of Congress or senator
whatever answered questions and did not
say the answer how do you ever trust
that system again you can't we're
literally he gets to laugh about it ten
years later yeah him Geithner all those
guys there's like a there's a there's
like a meme I think it's Timothy
Geithner I think he's at Davos or
something is on stage it's him and
Paulson and they're like cackling it's
not this interview but they're cackling
about like how they saved the world
broody haven't seen post us every once
in a while and it's great it's uh know
these people and just they think they
live on a difference here and that they
again it's the power hunger the
incentives of the system the way they're
currently set up allow those people to
get to those points and control the
system and they get it they get a lot of
power from that and that power corrupts
right and they don't care about the
little man I don't care about saving the
country everybody gets a little Ming of
[ __ ] all the houses got possessed
here's the crazy part about the whole
thing is I would actually make the
argument the actions they took prevented
further damage in that short period of
time but what I try to explain to people
is it's like saying to your kid hey I'm
gonna teach you how to swim and they
start swimming and you're walking next
to them in the pool and the second that
they start to drowned you save them and
then they now think because you continue
to let them swim that they know how to
swim and when you're not there later
they jump in the pool and they drown cuz
literally you've like trick them into
thinking it's okay
well that's basically what's happening
in the financial system in the sense of
hey we'll do this quantitative easing
thing and like what kind of like inflate
away the problems but at some point you
gotta pay for the sins like that's what
I like
whether it's over leveraged unprofitable
companies in the public markets whether
it's central banking [ __ ] like
whatever
you eventually have to pay for your sins
and I think that's the scariest thing
that we could face is it all happening
at once yeah well now it's gonna be
worse why then if we just let it know of
course the companies fail that should
have failed in 2008 now I mean with the
overnight repo operations like the BIS
came out and said there would have been
multiple LTCM long-term capital
management like blow ups if the Fed
didn't step in and do overnight repo
like these and it became apparent that
the people in need of that repo
liquidity were hedge funds doing
leveraged trades so that the Fed is now
stepping in into helping leveraged hedge
funds maintain their margin positions
like it's it there it was taboo to say
10 years ago but they're propping up the
market it's quite literally it's why the
short squeezes like we saw with Tesla
make me laugh right cuz it's just like
look you guys are all so [ __ ] smart
and here's a dude who literally you guys
just hammer on all day long you call
them a fraud an idiot whatever and by
the way all of that may be true but then
you get short squeeze literally they're
doing repo operations half a wall
street's crying and literally he's like
dude I just put the [ __ ] cool car and
you like watch this play out and it's
like that's like a very salacious
everyone wants to talk about that one
but this happens quite often where you
see all sorts of volatility like I
pulled up a chart of the VIX it's like
literally skyrocketing so right now
quite a while what Y basically was just
like hey guys there's a lot of trishul
investors who are like oh bitcoins too
volatile again we check out the VIX
lately right and over the last three is
it's just like [ __ ] open to the right
and so you look at it you're like every
asset has its time and the nice thing
about the trishal mortgage with lots of
liquidity and so usually the swings are
you know gold's down three three and a
percent today and of course you know a
Peter Schiff but dude your your rocks
are becoming less valuable right now
granted in the grand scheme of things if
you actually look at it rationally it's
3% nothing that up or down in a Bitcoin
day nobody blinks yeah it's just that
the markets have gotten so conditioned
for non-volatile days and kind of just
this smooth up and to the right but
that's not how markets work if you don't
manipulate them
yeah and it's again it's it's a product
of the short-term high velocity trash
economy we live in right like these
intraday movements people pay so much
attention to and really the people
should be taking step back and looking
and thinking about longer-term and again
it's like clickbait media's been brought
to the financial world as well people
are reacting to these quick movements
and
stock prices and again like I think
people need to lower their time
preference and it's a it'll be
interesting to see like we again it's
consensus out there right now that the
Fed is going to step in and prop up
markets like again that was taboo but
not even a decade ago maybe three years
ago that was taboo and now everybody is
expecting it and me I said this on
rabbit-hole recap yesterday just
heuristic aliy the fact that everybody
expects expects the Fed to step in which
they may try to step and but the fact
that we we we think it's going to happen
but everyone is consensus thought is the
problem yeah and and I'm just not
convinced it's gonna work this time
but do you think that it's almost not
even that we think it's gonna have we
want it to happen
look if everyone thinks people know like
they need it people need it to happen
yes but people were ever over leverage
in the traditional system they
definitely need it to happen and again
like it's clip in my theory of why the
Fed stepped in and sort of provided
liquidity to these hedge funds because
probably a lot of pensions have monies
in the hedge funds and gang going back
to demographics and all the boomers
retiring right now
and as they're retiring if you have the
system implode there gonna be chaos like
so here's my hot take when it comes to
pension I knew again nothing about the
pension world four years ago I've gone
and now met with a number of public
pensions corporate pensions accessor and
really started unpack like their
challenges from like the investor seat
from the CIO seats impossible job
because is a combination of pressure of
what we're investing in everyone's got
some [ __ ] scheme right it's like
Chamath going on CNBC me like ESG is a
fraud yeah like cookie whether you agree
with it or not like good for him for
saying it and then the pensions become a
just bait for people looking for
two-and-twenty okay so in the greatest
bull market in history like I don't
eighty percent of pensions
underperformed their benchmarks like
seven percent a year yeah like how does
that how do you [ __ ] underperform
seven percent fees even if there's fees
how do you [ __ ] still underperform
the marker is up 30% you didn't beat
seven yeah it's because we live in a
society where one of my partner's mark
always says he goes numbers aren't gonna
be exactly correct but directionally
correct for everyone computer scientist
graduate him
south korea graduates like 14 for every
one lawyer they graduate we graduate 40
and it's this whole idea of like they're
a country of wealth creation or a
country of wealth redistribution and so
if you're a pension investor what do you
do you're [ __ ] scared shitless you're
gonna get sued every time you make it
investments what do you do you just
diversify as much as possible and you
become super super risk-averse but like
that's not how you make money investing
yeah and part of that is what you're
talking about which is oh by the way
we're not gonna do the work ourselves
we're gonna hand the money to a bunch of
managers because if they [ __ ] up we can
fire them exactly right and so you get
into this weird weird world which by the
way the fee thing to me is hysterical
because mark told me a story that when
he got to I think was UNC and I might
[ __ ] up that he does a little bit but
when I get to you and see every was like
we don't pay uh like three and thirty or
something you know all these hedge funds
were coming up these crazy fee schedules
he goes guys I don't care if I pay one
in ten two and twenty three and thirty
or [ __ ] ten and the hunt and you know
eighty percent if the return we make is
the is still better than all the other
managers the fee schedule doesn't matter
right so like Jim Simons they've charged
like five and fifty know what [ __ ] for
like 25 years
but his average annualized return over
that span is 66 percent net of fees
pretty bang-up so you're hey hey dude
I'll pay whatever you want you give me
66 percent or hey and so it's just like
by the way that's one guy who can't be
replicated right he's he's far and away
the best whatever at what he does we
should look at this
the problem isn't quote-unquote fees
it's the manager who makes ten percent a
year and then charges fees and then
turns around hands to pension three
percent annualized returns like dude
these people aren't going to get what
they were promised and on top of that
you have the the passive investing
mindset right where you have all these
funds sort of moving in lockstep in the
same direction again demographics come
into play everybody goes to liquidate
those passive funds that are in the same
market it's like
just the math is pretty straightforward
you're gonna pull out all that value
from from those funds and things are
gonna fall in price have you heard of I
think it's Nevada or Utah the state
pension manager have you heard what he
did yeah he went him you tired
fires like literally everyone I think he
kept like one person took all of the
capital back and put it all in like
low-cost passive indexes and was
outperforming all of his peers and
everyone was like what the [ __ ] and he
was like basically run a bull market
it's gonna go up you guys are all gonna
have to pay fees plus your managers
cannot perform whatever this profile I
was reading was basically like what the
[ __ ] do you do every day they had a
pitcher and he's like sitting at his
desk and I'd sure be like that dudes a
boss st. Michael berry just waitin yeah
like whether you think he's right or not
what you know whatever it's just the
fact that like obvious has a very low
time preference doesn't think he's got
to be the smartest guy in the room and
he just looks at kind of like a Warren
Buffett like why are you guys paying all
these hedge fund managers just buy
indexes whatever and like maybe he's
right maybe he's not but you got a
respect somebody who has the
intellectual courage to still have
independent thought in today's day and
age when everyone is rushing to pass the
funds except to the you know herd
mentality I'll go into 28 cetera yeah
dad so again I think it's it's a weird
predicament we find ourselves in like I
think the financialization of the world
to a certain extent has created a lot of
passivity and decision-making from
individuals right like financial
literacy is something that should be
more of a priority for individuals
taking care of your land bitcoin is a
huge driver of this for me personally
like I feel more confident in my
personal decisions I control my money
and it's worked out up to this point
because I feel like a better educated
and making more educated decisions as an
individual instead of allocating that to
somebody else who has maybe perverse
incentives to to push into something
with higher fees or just go along with
the crowd and able to get lazy at their
job
Mourad told me this and mecir was the
one really his brother hammered at home
for me which was this idea of like that
teacher that firefighter that mid-level
manager whoever we as a society want
them to be great at their job and then
we also require them through financial
incentives to be professional investors
as well yes and that's really hard one
and two is a non realistic expectation
we have so something like a Bitcoin
where it's disinflationary monetary
schedule deflationary supply demand
economics provide you know are applied
etc if all of a sudden you can have an
asset where somebody simply good at
their job and there's this quote-unquote
savings technology it really does change
the way the relationship people can have
with their wealth or their money without
having to revamp the education system
yeah well the Chase for yield is forcing
people again to reallocate their money
to others make if you have a sound
currency like basically a savings
technology where people's are able to
save their purchasing power over time
instead of having to chase that yield in
stock markets via fund managers what
what have you attention funds
you basically decrease the amount of
decision-making and stress right he's so
incredible people just I mean this is
what Monsieur touches on if they could
just have their time valued in a hard
currency that preserves purchasing power
over time so my favorite meme on the
internet is it's a tweet that
screenshotted and it's a CNN just said
the world is in two hundred seventeen
trillion dollar debt who the [ __ ] do we
owe money to the Decepticons right like
the world is in debt it's just this like
incestuous I owe you money you owe me
money you know the guy down the street
owes me money
we don't what's going on I mean the
future generations of that money right
its future production that we're
promising and this is what I mean mmm
tea it's got a half proponents so
they'll say yeah that's their exact
argument who we owe to we owe to
ourselves like we can
printed to oblivion so I talked to a
Robert Breedlove about this in the last
episode Hong Kong essentially doing
helicopter money yeah right
they literally that the part that
cracked me up is the us-based media
mainstream media is usually using the
work or the phrase Cash Giveaway
and their coverage of this like what the
[ __ ] is going on yeah they're given each
citizen 10,000 Hong Kong dollars like
twelve hundred US dollars
seven million people I mean by the way
great for the people rights easy said
this to me he was like usually the
people don't get it usually the
government would print the money in like
injected into the financial system and
somehow the people would never see the
benefit if you're a Hong Kong citizen
you get 10,000 Hong Kong dollars like
that's food right or that you know
that's something that you can actually
do but it's not sustainable no not at
all but given the like in 2008 given the
choice to if you were only given two
choices bail out the banks or give money
to the people the people I would take
the ladder give it to the people that
proved I mean again in the last 12 years
has just been a hijacking of wealth and
a reallocation of wealth from the
poorest to the richest and there's just
pure asset flows from the spigot of
money creation to financial assets and
real estate but my big thing lately is I
didn't didn't understand how many
leaders in the financial world have been
charged with crimes like Jamie Dimon
right Christine Lagarde like she was
found guilty and serve any time yeah she
was at the IMF what is the
what was she charged with so she was
convicted this is a 2016 article in an
International Monetary Fund chief at the
time Christine Lagarde has been
convicted over a role in a controversial
400 million pound payment to a
businessman they found her guilty of
negligence for failing to challenge the
state arbitration payout the friend of
the former French was the former a
French president and now she's the
chairwoman of the ECB like yeah she's
one of the most important central
bankers in the world now she was when
she was at the IMF - but again we live
in two-tier justice system these people
live above the law and then they try to
lecture to everybody below them on how
they should live their lives I mean it's
it's right in plain sight and for some
some reason we still pay credence to
these people when they are criminals at
the end of the day this is the reason
why I think bitcoin is such a no-brainer
I'm trying to pull up this this photo of
her signing the dollar no I've seen that
one too but she uh she went to dinner I
think it's back into semifinal quick but
basically she went to dinner and oh here
it is so the tweet says I was pleased to
invite my new Governing Council
colleagues to join me at an off-site
retreat yesterday we discuss in an open
an informal setting the running of the
Governing Council as accompanied by this
photo and there's like 24 25 people in
the photo there's not a person under the
age of what looks like 45 or 50 every
single person's white the people who
still have hair have white hair she's
the only woman at the table and it
literally looks like if you just put
them in like a villain movie head looks
like like looks like Austin Powers dr.
evil has his ground table and and
they're in a for those who don't see the
photo they're in this like very
magnificent old school literally
gold-trimmed photo you know
a wall big drapes a big chandelier at
the table etc and it's just like I think
I might even tweeted this photo I've
been like do you trust these people or
do you trust math alright and like
that's fine there's plenty of people who
say like I so trust these people they're
human whatever but over a long period of
time more people will trust math than
any group of humans right but this photo
just to me like hits home so much
yeah I mean again going back to the
comments on a few people trying to
micromanage a complex system Bitcoin fix
us this is a huge meme and I believe
Bitcoin will fix a lot of things it's
definitely not a panacea but again it
provides the opportunity to develop a
new financial system in an emergent
fashion like anybody can buy hardware
plug in a minor and mined Bitcoin
directly they could work for a Bitcoin
directly and when they're doing that
they're buying into a system that is not
controlled in that fashion is bottom-up
has been bottom-up for the first 11
years of this existence and I would
bargain or sue but I would argue that
it'll stay that way for quite some time
forever hopefully and again it's
completely it's an affront to the way
things are done now and we're gonna look
back and it's going to be obvious that
it was stupid to have to think that 12
men and women in a room speaking of the
Fed particularly and then Christine
Lagarde at the ECB as well and that
group of 25 people to think that they
can micromanage a global economy like
it's asinine it doesn't make any sense
and Bitcoin provides the opportunity to
opt out of that and say hey it doesn't
seem crazy if you don't know there's
another way once you realize there's
another way and you understand how the
other way works then it seems the same
yeah but it takes a lot I think it's the
thing with bitcoins a mindfuck takes a
while to understand and that's the I go
back to financial literacy people don't
know what money is or how the financial
system works today so that I think
there's a concerted effort to make it
that way and but once like nine people
out of ten
I don't do it that often anymore when I
would ask like is the dollar back my
gold they be like yes like people a lot
of people still think the dollars back
buy gold my question is always do you
understand that the dot like your money
gets less valuable every year but dollar
back my gold would seem like that's in
an even easier layup question and if 9
and 10 are getting that wrong geez yeah
but and that's the thing people do know
they they don't know it because prices
of the yeah they don't feel they can
feel it they don't and experience it
they just don't know what the cause is
they think corporations are paying them
less and Joe are you did you pull off
the buy bitcoin let's go fuss I don't
know how you just did that by the way
hold on time out for a second Joe has
figured out the live streaming and he's
figured out how to put graphics and now
obviously we just figured out that Joe
knows how to put images I feel like this
is gonna go real bad real fast
and he's gonna start throwing up things
on the screen that we're not paying
attention to Joe can you pull up a
picture of the Mexican central banker
Karstens he's now the head of the BIS
there's a picture of him eating a
sandwich at some point pull that up
that's the epitome of of the central
banking system we I know exactly a
Gustin customers only Karsten yeah I
don't know what photo you're talking
about but that I do know you'll say do
you do you think that bitcoin is such a
big idea that's why the quota code
intelligent people like reject the truth
right and the truth being Bitcoin is
based on verifiable information right
and what I was saying to Breedlove is
like most of these people and especially
in finance they try to find truth or
find facts or data in every aspect of
their life and all of their work that
they do in investing and then when it
comes to Bitcoin you're like hey man you
have to look very far like here's all
the information here's the Matta and
they're just like nah no way that
doesn't work which makes me believe like
no they do understand the value of it
it's just threatens the status quo and
therefore they don't want to I think
that's definitely a that's definitely
the case and then on top of that it's so
much sunk intellectual and financial
cost into their careers up to this point
it's heart and it's the saying it's hard
to teach an old dog new tricks and again
the sunk cost of reputation and capital
into the incumbent system is such that
if it's hard for them to admit that
something new is here and it may be
better yeah it also leads me to think
about I don't know what do we know what
the youngest president ever was in the
u.s. yeah he hurt JFK Obama I imagine
the youngest person to assume the
presidency was Theodore Roosevelt and he
seated to the office at the age of 42
years and 326 43 years old the reason
why I immediately thought of that is if
you look at the election now all like
everyone's 60 plus you're saying that's
pretty crazy and one of my big themes
over the next few years it's like
there's this rage against not only
institutions but also the belief that
like you need 40 years of experience in
order to do a job and I think we saw
this a little bit with like congressmen
and congresswomen being elected that
were in their 30s and much earlier
I'm waiting though for like the 35 year
old presidential candidate to like show
up and just beg if I call you guys the
president's a dying breed I think the
rocks gonna be the president yeah only
because it is official that the
President sees a popularity contest and
he's the most recognized person he's got
charisma and he's so physically
intimidating they have you put him on a
debate state like Mike bloom what does
Mike Bloomberg say to him he's literally
just looking at a 6-5 guy right even
Trump Trump I think is six four right
the rock would just dwarf it but it's so
again going back to the inflection
points like the structure of our
government was put in place in 1776 like
200 mm-hmm almost 50 years away from
that it's just the structure of our
government is not built for again the
way things work today how fast
information moves and what what is the
function of a congressman a
representative why were they created in
the first place they were created
because they would show up in a local or
excuse me a centralized place DC
Philadelphia at one point New York at
one point and basically speak on behalf
of their constituents they acted as a
voice for their constituents because
their constituents we're not physically
able to show up and speak now that we
have the Internet
that's not the case anymore people speak
for themselves immediately and have
their voices heard online like the the
actual mechanics of of the government
officials I think and their reason for
for being like are made moot today
because because of technology like we
don't need to allocate our voices to
politicians and that's why I think we
should how does it change you have to
have like a balkanization or any where
things get more localized I think I
think we need to go more local we need
to we can't have the federal government
dictating in large swaths what everybody
across the country and every
jurisdiction should do it just doesn't
work that way it shouldn't work that way
we need to get we need to make the
federal government smaller and give
states rights more of a try at the state
level and then from the state level down
to the city level in Township level as
part of this that if you go with that
message it just doesn't happen like if
you if you basically ask for permission
to some degree it's really hard to
accomplish it but something like Bitcoin
and other pieces of technology that
in a non-violent way just simply give
the power back like the technologies the
solution rather than trying to operate
within the box of egg let's go debate
you know at the Town Hall no exactly
like guys that's why I focus on Bitcoin
I don't watch this to pates or anything
like that like I think you know all
around I'm high life at least it's gonna
be more worthwhile to focus on Bitcoin
cuz again its people call it [ __ ] you
money because you have it you could say
[ __ ] you I'm gonna do what I want and
then I'll enable that localism that that
I was just talking about right people
deciding for themselves to invest in
their local economies and and again
being ground up and a book I just have
been reading it finished and have been
like Reese Kimmi
strong towns it's a book written by a
man named Charles Marone he's from
Minneapolis and it's an incredible book
and again it goes back to time
preference and the hasty decisions made
for growth at all cost and basically
after world war ii and we went out and
built people got away from cities built
suburbs and infrastructure outside of
cities and we basically turned our backs
on hundreds of that or thousands of
years of humanity figuring out how to
build sustainable cities by trial and
error slowly over time and after World
War two we had a bunch of money we had
the dollar was a reserve currency and we
just wanted to experiment with expanding
into suburbs and into in away from
cities and when we did that we didn't
realize we're creating like in software
people talk about tech debt like if you
have too much tech debt you can
basically hurt your product in the
future because you have so many things
got to fix as you try to scale and it
can curb scaling at a certain point we
have that in America in the form of
infrastructure debt like we've expanded
our infrastructure specifically after
World War Two in the 60s 70s and so you
have roads pipes dude saying subway
shout out to the l not get shut down
after the somebody got paid off
somewhere right but like compare this
subway to Japan yeah but we and but
outside of the cities it's even worse
where you have like town just being
deserted and as soon as one house one
homeowner decides not to keep up the
facade of their house and it goes goes
sort of rotting it sort of decays the
value of the houses around it and their
hoods die quickly and you have basically
a generations worth of the ability to
live in these these towns and then after
30 years we're finding that a lot of
Middle America and suburbs are decaying
and that's why you're seeing a lot of
people come back to cities and stuff
like that and again going back the time
preference it was decision made in haste
because we thought it was a cool idea at
the time but we weren't thinking about
generations ahead what we would have to
do to sort of service and maintenance
maintain all everything that we built
and so that's why and that was allowed
to happen basically after why not the
gold standard - well at some point the
incentives get so screwed up that people
who are sitting in the seat are acting
rationally but the long-term impact they
don't care about because not going to be
there exactly they don't they don't
answer the bell if you will right no
that's uh get cheesy with it every once
in a while but like I do think we should
adopt what's called like a seven
generations mentality the Iroquois
nation it's debatable whether they
specifically said seven generations but
still I think the concept is good
we should have seven generation mindset
were you thinking about the seven
generation ahead of you like do
something today do something today that
would benefit them and sprawling into
like an urban landscape or sub urban
landscape like we did after World War
two proved to only think one generation
had
and we're gonna pay the price for that
especially with demographics turning as
well pretty pretty it's gonna be a hard
price to pay and again we're gonna look
back in retrospect ago we were going
through this right now yeah it's
happening like I interviewed a guy on
the podcast Chris Arnaud a and he wrote
a book called dignity where he he was a
Wall Street trader at City and after Oh
8 he decided to become a photojournalist
and basically go to middle America where
people were voting for Trump and find
out why they were voting for Trump and
it's basically the the reason they voted
for Trump was because their towns are
decaying all their jobs are shipped away
it's the pharmacist is the guy who you
seen the documentary they're just
getting [ __ ] ravaged yeah and this is
a serious conversation we need to have
his country like where the [ __ ] do we
want to go we're on a bike right now
that's the thing like where you got to
keep going the way it's structured right
now and I think we need to have hard
conversations of hey let's get off the
bike growth at all cost doesn't make
sense it's not worthwhile and we need to
recalibrate our mindset I think Bitcoin
again I say this a lot big work bitcoins
gonna change us more than we change
Bitcoin the protocol it's gonna change
our mindset and our time preference
that's why I focus on it cuz I think it
forces people to think seven generations
ahead and lower their time preference
it's kind of like Amazon right where
Amazon had this like really really
incredible growth mindset they basically
ran a break even operation never made
money get as big as they possibly could
and once you hit some kind of growth
milestone it's not that they plateau but
now they're you're optimizing changes
now they're creating incredible amount
of cash right and it's not so much like
growth at all cost is bad its growth at
all costs at certain times is good once
you hit some inflection point though you
can't do it forever and I think we see
this with companies right in the public
markets I think we see it definitely
private companies that are burning cash
but we see with the economy as well and
it's so it's kind of like at some point
you go from we got to get from not
established to establish because we're
established then it's all about this
long-term how do we stay here forever
that's knowing when growth is worthwhile
and when ya to put your foot on the
brake say hey we don't need to O be
rational Jesus that would be a [ __ ]
wild idea don't need to go into debt -
and that's the thing Chuck talks about
in the book strong towns a lot is a lot
of these towns going into debt to keep
up maintenance cost to keep up
maintenance of the things they've
already built and then they want to be
able to show their constituents that
they're growing so they'll try and
expand cities and towns and they're just
adding to that infrastructure deck
slowly over time Joe you got the photo
let's see he's gonna show us this photo
and then we're uh this is the one let's
see I'm calm
Joe is currently pulling up Gus think
personification of central banking yeah
let's see what uh what's your new
favorite book you can't say we said last
time while we're waiting oh wait he is
it was a meme oh no you're gonna pull
multiple ones there was multiple ones
yeah
man there's sandwiches everywhere in
that photo I like by the way how you
said to Joe hey pull the picture of my
meeting a saying Joe pulled up with me
[Laughter]
the fact that he put up a meme is the
personification of this whole [ __ ]
operation right what uh I appreciate you
putting them over my face in the video
too
and that you know it would be a great
segment is to do this and then we could
talk like we were central bankers hey
man you hungry
I'm starving what a prince of money what
uh what's your new favorite book other
than strong downs it's an old book I'm
reading human action right now by Ludwig
von Mises missus excuse me
Mises I always [ __ ] that up is it Mises
yeah pretty sure I've been directed in
the past yeah
thank you word for it I could be wrong I
could be wrong
I'm reading that right now favorite book
I think I'm gonna go back and read
insert oh I actually had that on my mind
shower thoughts recently like I should
go back to read full by randomness and
black swuan skin in the game he's
incredible
yeah that's uh you want to know what I
would love to see I would love to see
navall Talib Kathy would and like I
don't have to come over the fourth
person not even weekly monthly and
people get a write-in and there's some
sort of like voting system of like
here's the most popular questions and
it's almost kind of like the at least
with navall and to leap for sure and
Kathy I think just has a very different
mindset female perspective etc they're
like the modern-day philosophers right
and you basically don't like what do you
guys think
okay just see like cuz I'm because they
have such different perspectives than
like the everyday person yeah I mean I'm
just fascinated by I miss em and I see
him to lab like very like I think his
writing is so glue Sid and so clear and
the way explains everything especially a
summit asymmetry and the probabilistic
nature of the world and the randomness
of the world and he does a very good job
of explaining emergent systems to in his
series of books via languages and stuff
like that and how languages have emerged
I would love to pick his brain
particularly about what's going on right
now like seeing him talk about the
corona virus more recently balaji could
be another one mawashi yeah
scott adams another one that
to go up there Scott sky is that the
dobrica yeah did you read a win big Lee
I don't know okay so this is the one
book somebody I won't say who told me to
read it but somebody in like the
investing world told me to read this and
I was like dude I'm good because I think
it literally has a picture at Trump on
it uh-huh and I just I was gonna take a
super politicized book but basically
what he does is he talks all about like
weapons-grade persuasion and how Trump
very early on he knew hey this guy's
gonna win the presidency and what he
thinks like one of the examples he gives
is a Hillary Clinton had a hold
data-driven team around like what their
slogan was gonna be so they came up with
a nice low be noise test Trump walked in
a room we just look he's like make
America great and then like it works and
he like like Dave Portnoy he Trump knows
how to lean and when when it's the right
time and that's actually nothing if
somebody you want to hear speak and
somebody who's very controversial and
after watching a lot of his talks I sort
of don't understand why Steve Bannon
like I would like he he is very lucid
thinker and very lucid explainer of his
view of the world that is somebody I
would love to sit down and talk with as
well because I think that was like a the
media portrayed in the Sun like dev
Psychopaths yes I can I make a guess
right now I'm gonna cheat a little I
have one piece of information about you
but I'm gonna guess that the video you
watch that changed your mind on him was
the real vision interview Kyle bass and
Steve Bannon that wasn't I mean I have
watched that he actually there's a but
that wasn't the one that changed your
mind that wasn't one change I've seen
that I've been on a Steve banning binge
in the last few months because again
like I was I caught that he's alright
white supremacist yeah when I watched
the Kyle bat the one that I just told
you that's the one that changed my mind
cuz I was like holy [ __ ] this dude is
[ __ ] smart
yeah and he is nothing like what he was
being portrayed as yeah and and if
you're out there listening you think
Steve ban is the devil
I would highly recommend you go watch it
he's got that's the thing he's got a
plethora of hour to two hour long videos
out there we just explains his view of
the world very clearly and it makes
sense to me
like in the last election and since
Trump's been in office Russia has been
the boogeyman he makes a very compelling
case that we should be focused more on
China yeah so this is all right this
last time we talked about that would get
the hell out of here you gotta go home
said why is this model this media model
of long-form conversations right someone
other podcast that you I would do I
didn't understand the power of it until
I saw Bernie Sanders going Joe Rogan I
don't agree with anything Bernie Sanders
says at least I thought before he went
on this podcast I still don't agree with
99% of what Bernie Sanders says for the
most part but I was shocked at the
contrast between the way he's portrayed
by the media even though I get up see
him do a debate and interview a speech
whatever and the guy who was answering
the questions with Joe for two hours he
was way more intelligent he was way less
crazy he had thought out his ideas way
more than I'd ever thought you mean like
all of these things and it was damn we
as a society could benefit one from just
talking to people who we disagree with
etc because we I've said it's helpful
but to the media formats changing and
like rather than have all these
candidates go onstage and just yell and
scream at each other and like try to get
headlines and dunk on each other like
basically like a virtual dunk on each
other right have them just go do like a
three-hour segment and they had to be
the rogue I could literally be with
somebody from the political media and
just ask them all the questions and let
them talk and then provide that to
people I bet you that those videos would
be the most popular videos this the
network's ever played and the people
would actually be more educated all the
candidates yeah but I don't think the
network's want that to happen all right
I think they're trying to push of course
you saw ads
and I do think there's a like Bernie got
[ __ ] over in the last election at the
DNC
I mean that's pretty well when you're
trying up did it seems like trying to do
it again I'm like you like I'm I don't
agree with Bernie's policies at all but
it does seem like the the populist
movement on the left is behind him and
for some reason the Democratic Party
doesn't want him to be on stage I was
listening to New York Times The Daily uh
somebody had told me you know go check
this out I didn't realize how popular it
was so I was the only episode ever
listened to I was the other day and they
they brought a reporter and he was
talking about Bernie Sanders got a visit
from the FBI basically saying hey like
Russia's trying to help your campaign
and I guess at least what the reporter
said is Bernie didn't disclose they
didn't have to but it just didn't
disclose that and then it came out that
the FBI went and talked to some other
campaigns etc and so somehow in there it
got leaked that they went and saw Bernie
Sanders a month before and his whole
thing was basically like of course it
got leaked
you know like a day before the caucus or
whatever and at one point the host of
the podcast guy goes well why does Trump
seem to congratulate Bernie Sanders and
he's like well because Trump probably
thinks he's the weakest candidate yeah
but like then you go and you see Trump
is live tweeting like congratulations
Bernie good job it's like what world do
we live I don't know man it's [ __ ] we
live in a weird world and then go max
like what we said earlier as individuals
like you really need to critically think
for yourself like that is gonna be
imperative moving forward and how do you
filter information like you probably
more than most I know do a good job it
seems like what's your strategy for
filtering information so you read good
high quality stuff other than
subscribing to your newsletter you I put
a lot of competing views on the same
less I use TweetDeck TweetDeck is the
only way to consume Twitter in a good
way in my mind you create lists you
throw them up on tweet deck and then
within tweet deck and you put competing
views on these lists and over time
you basically see what people say how it
lines up it's what actually happens what
has happened in the past and then you
just develop trust with some people you
follow do you curate them like you're on
a list for me and then also you say
something stupid you take people off the
list or do you pretty much keep it I
keep them on just because again like
echo chambers are like a big thing and
like Bitcoin Twitter and stuff like that
but just to stay honest I think you got
it you got to know how the other not
even the other side you know everybody's
thinking and then develop your mindset
based on your experiences from that and
it takes time like the filtering my
filtering process took years of building
list and sort of understanding the
people on that list and how they react
to certain events and how correct they
were over time yeah it's just not gonna
happen overnight it takes time makes
sense still believe in aliens yeah just
checking all right one question you have
for me that we could finish this up but
by the way top trending now on Twitter
it's promoted is this is how we Sonic I
feel like you got to throw a final
thought about your favorite drive-in
fast-food sometime next week but go
ahead what's your question chick-fil-a
and question you always put me on the
spot with this right you were talking
about like the Trent what do you were
your thoughts on the trends and like
independent media going forward oh I
think game over for the big guys other
than the one controversial thought I
think I have David Parral came in here
and David he showed me a studying I'll
caveat this because people will freak
the [ __ ] out the data that he showed me
says what I'm about to say but I didn't
go see how they calculated it whatever
but it looked at the New York Times and
since they installed the hard paywall
the use of very left-leaning language
woke all of these terms and words etc
has explode
I don't think that they're going into an
editorial room and be like yeah we
should uh you know lean into this right
but one of the things that he really
pushed me to think about is like look
like take pay walls at the major media
corporations we can say that it's still
the New York Times or whatever but they
kind of become these very ideological
things because if you're now the paying
person you're not the advertisers don't
pay you pay how many people have the
intellectual honesty to keep paying for
some they don't agree with not that many
right so you almost be like the
publisher now is writing for the
audience and so what do they do they
lean into what we know the audience
likes this so they start to move more in
that direction and this was over a
couple of months and just the language
you use right you start talking about
certain topics and it kind of pulls the
thing there and so I think that one that
means the traditional large publishers
are gonna become looking more like
bloggers style opinionated
you're gonna try to mimic it yeah like
independent type publishers but they'll
still be the large guys to is you'll see
an explosion like you know sub stack
obviously I think is those types of
tools that will allow people to kind of
build their own things etc three
podcasts I actually think American
citizens are really bad at writing in a
highly / generalized way it's much
easier to just talk and so I think
you'll can do you see that explosion but
then the other piece is this idea of
like citizen journalism kind of like
what blah she's done with the
coronavirus stuff people now realize
there's a social reward for being the
best voice on something regardless of
your position in society and so you've
seen this now with like Tim Poole became
super popular with all of the like riots
and and protests and stuff with like the
civil rights type stuff Balaji's done a
great job with coronavirus I think
you're starting to see people say like
I'm personally interested in a topic and
there's a social role with the guy you
see the guy in the
the Japanese ship that wouldn't leave I
had it was there somebody reporting from
there so dudes on a cruise off that ship
dudes on a cruise everyone gets Corona
it's like 600 people got good in fact it
was a terrible quarantine strategy and
he started tweeting or posting or
whatever and started to gain a little
bit of Fame from it and following and
they came and tried to get everyone who
hadn't contracted it yet off the ship
and he wouldn't leave and wouldn't let
his wife leave so he got addicted to the
fame I I don't know really what was
going on back home soon but literally
like he was like I'm not leaving like
like I got a job to do like I'm about a
livestream the corona fire is not worth
it son yeah and so it's just like that's
like an extreme you know example but
like you almost get this world where
like people feel an obligation and they
have the tools
Shihong Hong Kong protests you see
people stepping with a doctor that in
China like he felt compelled and crazy
he's actually started I mean rest in
peace him stepping up and then being
correct
the CCP making him come out with a
statement against what he originally
reported and then dying when he probably
was correct a warning everybody of
coronavirus in December was really
igniting from what I understand animal
spirits within China people are pissed
off that this man who may have been able
to not prevent but alert alert and
contain neaten may have been able to
contain the virus obviously more than
they have now at this point and that's a
citizen journalist the doctor who just
felt like he needed to stand up for what
he thought was right one of the things
that I started to push myself and I
think I'm gonna start challenging people
with is when you read the news meaning
not the individual citizen journalists
stuff right
mainstream media whatever terminology
one use historically we've lived our
lives default it's true
if you switch that not to default its
lot it's untrue but default this is an
opinion I need to investigate true or
not true right so kind of like default
neutral the way you think about the
information you consume completely
changes yeah this this really hit home
for me with the Quran of iris
particularly like I was out there like I
I was out there speaking more
confidently three weeks ago than I have
I'm comfortable speaking now I honestly
wait why
like because you don't know yeah I don't
know I honestly don't know what's going
on on the ground like the videos of the
people welding the door shut like I know
I can't corroborate them I've been able
to find it seems like it may be nursing
contradicting like people like oh that's
my neighborhood and they both say two
different things yeah and then I've
Bitcoin friends in and around China who
have said it may be the Chinese
government's overreacting and then you
then you listen the people saying that
the the numbers being reported are far
under what's actually happening it's
just again in the sovereign actually
mean the Information Age confusion is
going to reign supreme and with
coronavirus I'm very confused well and
this last thing I'll leave you with this
this is all it just the actual facts of
the information we're not even talking
about doctoring videos or audio
interview where it's like now it's goes
from confusion to like active
disinformation we're still just in the
confusion phase and I don't [ __ ] know
what's going on you don't know what's
going on like I don't think anybody
listen to this knows what's going on so
what happens when then we enter a world
where people are actively trying to give
you the figs yeah like that that's what
makes me want to come move to the woods
get a farm just chill all right
how can people subscribe to the
newsletter TFT CIO you can also buy
merch there yeah I don't know I guess
his sup freaks hat on and when we were
checking in with security the security
guy downstairs immediately eyes wide
up freaks it's a great conversation
starter best way subscribe newsletter
find me on Twitter at Marty bent I have
my pin tweet there a link to subscribe
you don't have to subscribe it's just my
weird thoughts on Bitcoin and macro and
philosophy with a final thought at the
end Joe is a [ __ ] expert look at you
got tales from the crippe logo in the
top right and then the podcast hills
thank you Jeff I've been crushing it I'm
telling you man he's about to be
dangerous so he's literally got your
photo up here he's got all the [ __ ]
information if if he has another three
days with this I feel like I'm gonna
come in here and he's gonna have a green
screen yeah we're gonna be at the beach
i man listen thank so much for coming to
do this I noticed we spent a lot of time
talking but hopefully all of you freaks
in Marty's world enjoyed this now thank
you for have